panie premierze Morawiecki
i jest pan dzisiaj w dobrej formie
kłamie pan Jak zawsze
OD lat mówiliście o tym żeby zamrażarka nie działała
ale przez 1.000 dni zamroziliście
funduszy z unii europejskiej
jesteście formacją polityczną
która utrudnia rządzenie
a pan panie premierze
wygłaszał pan dzisiaj tutaj ekspozę
to zamiast takiego krótkiego ekspozę
może przyjdzie pan tutaj
i przedstawi ekspozę swojego rządu tymczasowego
bo będzie pan rządził 2 tygodnie
ale wstyd jest taki
że nie potrafi pan przyjść pomimo
że razem już siedzicie
i powiedzieć kilku znanych co chcecie robić
dzisiejszą większość sejmową namawiacie
żebyśmy coś procedowali
ale prawda jest taka
że wy nie macie co procedować
bo wstydzicie się tego
że żeście polskę przez 8 lat niszczyli